Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson has now gone fully
homophobic on Pete Booted Judge or booted judge,
as some like to say he booted judge rather has
taken paternity leave. He and his husband have
adopted twins. And Tucker Carlson going in
on what? What is he doing? Breastfeeding,
huh? Is that why he's taking time off? Is it?
He's taking time off to learn how to breastfeed?
Tucker Carlson mocks Pete Budda Judge's
paternity leave as learning how to breastfeed.
Fox News host Tucker Carlson mocked Pete
Budda judge for taking paternity leave.
Carlson equated booted judge who is gay, taking
paternity leave to learning how to breastfeed.
Fox News host such as Jesse Watters previously
bragged about the network offering paternity
leave. Let's take a look at the video clip. Here
is the homophobic attack on Pete Buda judge kind
of mixed into some pseudo political stuff, but
Speaker 4: still, the White House does not
seem concerned. Peanut Butter
Judge has been on leave, by
Speaker 1: the way, but a judge
Speaker 4: is jobs since August after adopting
a child paternity leave. They call it trying to
figure out how to breastfeed. No word on that one.
But now he's back in office as the transportation
secretary, and he's deeply amused, he says.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's funny how the man
lead the supposedly manly right wingers who
are alpha, and they support the troops and they
support being tough and America being tough and
being tough at the individual level they have
as a hero. Tucker, who never served anywhere
making fun of Pete Boot, a judge who's a veteran
because he's taking care of his kids and mocking
him in a homophobic way. Now let me address one
other element of this. I got a few messages from
people and saw a ton of comments online, saying
stupid liberals saying This is homophobic. This
isn't homophobic at all. It might be stupid,
but it's not homophobic. Now I hesitate
to even, you know, sometimes when when people ask
for explanations for certain things, it's like
if you're asking for an explanation, you're not
going to understand it, you're not going to see
it. I don't know. I don't know that I can make you
see it, but let me try. Homophobia often seeks to
feminize men. Breastfeeding is something that
biological women do. And Pete Bhutta judge is gay.
It's a very, very simple feminization of a gay man
that that's all it is. And now that he's a father,
it's well, is he? Breastfeeding? Is that what's
going on? It's a very simple, lowbrow bigotry.
That's all it is. And Tucker Carlson's audience
absolutely loves it now. But a judge was asked
about this a couple of times. You know whether
whether Pete needs to respond or not sort of up
to Pete Boo to judge. But he said, I'm not
going to be apologizing to Tucker, Carlson
says. As you might imagine, we're bottle feeding
and doing it at all hours of the day and night,
and I'm not going to apologize to Tucker Carlson
or anyone else for taking care of my premature
newborn infant twins. The work that we are
doing is joyful, fulfilling, wonderful work.
It's important work. It's work that every American
ought to be able to do when they welcome a new
child into their family. I campaigned on that and
pointing out also that paternity paid paternity
and maternity leave in the United States are
far more rare than it is in many other wealthy
countries. So it's, you know, it's sort of
similar to the vaccine stuff with Tucker.
My assumption is he's been fully vaccinated for a
long time. He was first in line, but he's taking
the preconceived notions and biases of his
audience and the ignorance of his audience
to monetize opposition to vaccination requirements
and putting out stuff like the vaccines may have
killed tens of thousands of people, et etc.. I
don't think it's really what Tucker believes,
but it doesn't matter doesn't matter because the
impact on his audience and on the country is the
same whether Tucker really believes it or not.
I don't know. Nor do I care whether Tucker is
really homophobic or really has a problem with
paternity, the paternity leave. He is weaponizing
it and monetizing it because his audience
absolutely loves the thinly veiled homophobia.
And that's fundamentally what this is all about.
And everybody at Fox News seems to love it in
terms of what it does for their ratings. At the
same time, Fox has paternity leave. We know Jesse
Watters took it. And much like Fox, behind the
scenes, has one of the strictest vaccine mandates
of any large corporation. Yes. What happens on
air and what happens behind the scenes are two
very different things. We'll have more on this
on our Instagram. Make sure you're following us
on Instagram at The David Pakman Show and you can
follow me on Instagram as. Well, at David Pakman